respire bien font encore ça va mieux on
a peut-être atteint
je ne sais pas non ça ne va pas mieux
je ne sais plus que faible vous allez
bien moi je suis très ennuyé casimir a
le hoquet je n'ai aucun moyen efficace
pour le faire aussi bonjour je dis
bonjour casimir lézignan manger mais
qu'est ce que tu veux j'ai là où tu es
heureusement que tu arrives
je ne sais plus que ça rit il faut il
peut pas rester comme ça on en soit
c'est bien vrai alors t'as rien de
meilleur que ça dure mais julie pourquoi
lui avoir mis un sac de glace sur la
terre mais je me souviens que ma
grand-mère kg sans saddam hussein n'a
pas l'air d'avoir beaucoup d'effets
d'ailleurs au jeu les voyons soyons
sérieux retire lui ce sac de glace mais
moi je connais un remède efficace couple
et le hockey c'est une brusque
contraction du diaphragme une espèce de
deux secousses c'est quoi la loggia dia
c'est un muscle très large et très mince
qui se trouve entre la poitrine et
l'abdomen du voir ici là donc moi pour
lui ok je connais et remettez sur jeu
rapide et très gentille tu vas me
chercher ton casque un verre d'eau s'il
te plaît et toi casimir duval boire mais
attention pas de n'importe quelle façon
on sera content merci j'ai dit tu vas
casimir du prend le vert comme ça tu te
penches en avant tu mets tes lèvres sur
le bord externe les airs et duos et de
le voir mais à l'envers là entre-temps
faut tout blanc tonga pas là qu'elle
croit que c'est efficace
enfin enfin de casimiri oui voilà les
uns et à l'est mais je n'y arrive pas
c'est vraiment pas pratique dont total
j'aurais dû penser qu'avec ton gros
ventre tu veux pas te plier son groupe
mais tu sais très bien que je n'ai pas
ça en gros gros gros vos messages -
casimir je voulais pas te vexer mais
s'il eût été plus svelte et bien tu
aurais pu te te pencher en avant ce que
vous croyez pas quelque chose de plus
urgent que tous disputés à propos de la
grosseur du ventes de casino
je crois que ça va un peu mieux
bonjour tout le monde voilà tout est à
recommencer bonjour factor dont je fais
mais en fait tu sois style et bien
casimir a le hoquet et nous ne savons
pas comment le lui faire passer au
mambourg mais c'est très ennuyeux ça
pour sûr quasi mieux ne peut pas rester
comme ça tu tenais jolie moi moi une
fois ça m'est arrivé un loquet et alors
on m'a fait prendre plusieurs romed et
alors même vous savez pas ce qu'on m'a
fait faire ou écouter monsieur emile
campagne ce n'est pas leur en tient des
discours vous avez une solution et oui
oui bien sûr maintenant je ne sais pas
si casimir acceptera menditte toujours
vitrine et bien voilà et il suffit de
boire un grand verre d'eau et de
vinaigre blanc de vinaigre ah oui c'est
mieux avec deux grains de sucre temps
rim ou pour casimir mais non moment je
suis sûr que c'est très bien prépare le
mois mais ajoute un peu de moutarde des
2 caps réduit yaourt genevois casimir il
s'agit de tolkien d'une recette de
cuisine ont besoin l'occupent
[Applaudissements]
il ya longtemps qu'il est comme ça une
demi heure ça commence à devenir
dramatique ça j'espère que votre recette
est efficace parce que ça pour sûr
tenait chaque fois que j'ai eu
l'occasion fait ça j'ai bu un verre de
vinaigre avec de grandes souquet
immédiatement plus rien c'est normal
mais dépêchez vous qu'est ce qu'on fait
adaptation par 9 voix là haut
ouais bon je mettrais sheikh al bachir
amis mais pourquoi veux tu rassemblés là
tous
casimir n'est pas bien casimir ali
auquel nous ne connaissons pas les
moyens de lui faire passer mais il
fallait le dire plutôt mon cher ami moi
je connais un moyen très efficace de
moyens vous paraître un peu simple
n'est-ce pas mais je connais des gens de
très grande qualité qui l'ont
expérimenté et je puis vous attirez je
les connais elles s'en sont toujours
très bien portés ah ben je vais pas
attendre que l'on te voilà il suffit que
casimir boivent de l'eau en sus mec
temps les lobes des oreilles
cette décision me suis dit ce n'est pas
gentil ça vous savez très bien que
casimir n'a pas d'horaires des jeunes
autres moyens tout aussi efficace oui il
faut qu'ils avalent des grains de sucre
tout en tirant les cheveux
oui mais vous savez très bien non quand
je n'ai pas non plus de nos chauffeurs
ont complètement oublié raison kazemi ma
langue
c'est très grave je ne sais pas si tu te
rends compte à dieu dit pas des choses
comme ça monsieur disney venus les coups
de klaxon menacé rami faut regarder les
choses en face c'était le karaoké de
casino sans traitement immédiatement
cela peut s'aggraver mais enfin vous
êtes bien selon moi je suis dit je suis
sûr qu'il n'arrivera pas une extrémité
comme son jeu dès le chrono c'est rami
semaine y croire tellement j'ai une idée
je les tiens pas
les rockets de casimir à cesser
immédiatement vient jusqu'à ton casque
il doit bientôt rester un pistolet oui
bien sûr tu me donnes discrètement vous
allez me faire attaquer fort à kazimiya
oui certes assez sont ok allez me faire
d'amis méthode comment j'ai fait passer
comme le mien maintenant écouter je suis
humain j'ai une haute et vous n'avez
qu'à voir un grand verre de vinaigre
avec le sucre on vous vous chars les
oreilles et en vous tirant les cheveux